sam thompson wants to know
do you think biological
self-organization and emergence might be
proto-algorithmic
and then what would the implications of
for that what would the implications be
for science
i don't know what proto-algorithmic
means in this context
um i can take i can take a stab at uh
i think what might be an interesting
sense of it but i'm not sure that
captures what he was asking
the kind of thing that i think is
important sort of foundationally to
think about
is
where
do the set points of various
homeostatic systems come from so so
whether you have physiological
homeostasis or anatomical homeostasis
the ability of a system to get back to
the same
state even though it's it's perturbed
right one might ask where is that
information and an easy thing to say is
that well it's it's evolution provides
it because certain types of
set points are adaptive and other time
other types will will will not you will
not let you survive
and
that's okay except that now what we see
with these synthetic organisms is that
for example with the xenobots we can
take these frog skin cells and put them
in a new environment and within 48 hours
or so they
self-assemble into a new organism with a
new anatomy a new behavior and various
new capabilities
they never existed before they have no
lengthy history of selection on earth
right the the cells themselves evolved
for being really good at sitting on the
outside of a frog or a tadpole and
keeping out the bacteria they did not
evolve for the ability to get together
and run around by themselves and do
various things so that raises the
interesting question of where does that
actually come from right what the the
it's clear that there's incredible
plasticity of the hardware that's
encoded by the genome it can do all
sorts of novel things but where does
where do the specific things come from
and i don't know if this is what he
meant by proto-algorithmic but
you can sort of think about it one of my
favorite analogies is this thing called
the galton board i don't know if
everybody knows what that is but imagine
imagine a vertical piece of wood like
this it's a vertical piece of wood and
then you bang a bunch of nails into it
at you know regularly spaced intervals
just bang a bunch of nails into it you
take them you take a bucket of marbles
and you dump it into the top and they go
boom boom boom boom they all go and
every marble just sort of bounces
stochastically back and forth
if if if you've got enough marbles the
outcome is always going to be exactly
the same you're going to get this
beautiful bell curve
right if you just visualize and i
actually have toys of this you can
actually buy one on amazon it's like
twinkle from is right yeah yeah yeah
very very similar very similar but you
dump a whole you see if you dump one
marble you have no idea where it's gonna
end up but if you dump a bunch of
marbles in then on average you're gonna
get this beautiful bell curve and so you
can ask a simple question where is the
shape of this bell curve encoded was it
in the description of the wood no was it
in the layout of the nails no you could
put the nails almost any which way you
want was it in the in the recipe of
making this thing no um where was it and
so
you end up with this idea that
much like and this is certainly i'm not
the first person by far to to say this
this is a very old you know maybe maybe
pythagoras or plato had similar ideas
where
you would say that somewhere in an
important sense there are laws laws of
mathematics laws of computation that
exist independent of
uh
well independent they have an
independent existence and what happens
is that when we build specific kinds of
machines we couple to those laws and we
take advantage of them so for example if
you
build a machine that looks like a galton
board you get to couple to the rules of
mathematics that give you this beautiful
shape you didn't have to specify the
shape ahead of time you get the shape
for free by building a device that can
couple to those laws if you discover a
transistor which is basically just a
voltage-gated current conductance right
it's like a little tiny synapse you know
it's the same as a gap junction or an
ion channel as soon as you've you've
made that little machine you can couple
to these amazing laws of computation
that tell you for example that if you
have a bunch of nand gates you can build
anything well where did that fact come
from you know these truth tables or if
you know two angles of a triangle you
automatically know the third way where
that come from so so where is that so so
maybe that's what he meant by
proto-algorithmic but it's the idea that
there are these rules and some of the
some of them are physics some of them
are mathematics and some of them are
computation
you can if you make the right kind of
device you can reap the benefits of of
some of those laws and evolution does
this all the time evolution discovers
certain pieces of hardware that then let
you do amazing amazing things because
you're leveraging these laws that are
out there that are invisible to you
until you've built the right hardware